Düşünüyorum öyleyse varım
tüm filozoflar felsefe dillerini düşünme
üzerine kurmuşlar düşünceyi
yorumlamışlar Peki biz ne demişiz Düşün
düşün Yoktur işin
Aristo Descartes Sokrates
hayatları boyunca
düşünmeyi sorgulamışlar Bu yüzden şunu
çok merak ediyorum Acaba bunu ilk ne
zaman sorgulamaya başladılar
Ben bunu ilk defa sorgulamaya
başladığımda Henüz daha 4-5
yaşlarındaydım
ve
evin salonunda koşturuyordum evin
salonunda bir anda durdum
benimden düşünceler geçiyor kendi
kendime konuşuyorum
bu çok garipti
bunu fark etmek Bende çok garip bir
aydınlanma yarattı
düşüncelerimle kolumu kaldırabiliyorum
yürüyebiliyorum gitmek istediğim yerin
kararını verebiliyorum
bu öyle bir aydınlanmaydı ki
bütün hayatıma yön verdi
ve ne zaman bir sıkıntı hissetsem
herhangi bir konuda bir problem yaşasam
kendime hep şunu söyledim
olduğun yerde dur düşün ve bunu önce
zihnimde çöz
Tabii küçükken bunu çok faydalı işler
için kullanmadım mesela Annem dışarı
çıkmamıza izin vermediği zaman
dışarı balkondan topu atıp anne Top
dışarı çıktı derdim ve bu şekilde izin
alarak dışarı çıkabilirdim ya da evde
kağıtların üzerine yazdığım para da
haliyle kendi para birimi icat etmiştim
ve bu şekilde evde abime istediğim her
şeyi yaptırabiliyordum galiba küçükken
biraz dolandırıcıymışım
Tabii küçük yaşlardan itibaren
teknolojiye bilime elektroniğe çok
meraklı bir çocuktum
ve bu yüzden
içini merak ettiğim için bütün
oyuncaklarımın içini parçaladım
2000 yıllarının başında evimize
bilgisayar girmişti Henüz daha 8
yaşındaydım
ve o dönemlerde
bilgisayarla tanışmak benim problem
çözme yeteneğimi
bilgisayarları da kontrol etme çabasına
dönüştürdü ve küçük yaşlardan itibaren
Çok araştırdım çok öğrendim Çok çalıştım
ve yazılım öğrendim
lise üniversite zamanlarıma geldiğimde
yazılımlar artık para kazanmaya
başlamıştım
ve gelecekteki hayalim artık belliydi
yazılım şirketi sahibi olmaktı bütün
hayallerimi Buna göre koruyordum
üniversitede okurken
aynı zamanda bilgisayar laboratuvarında
çalışıyordum
bilgisayar laboratuvarında çalıştığım
dönemde
Arkadaşlarımla birlikte de projelerde
çalışıyorduk ve bu işten para
kazanıyordum
hayallerime Doğru giden süreçte olmak
istediğim yerdeydim ve o zamana kadar
gerçekten kendimi çok geliştirdim
Ama bu yaptığım çalışmalar öğrendiğim
şeyler sanki küçük yaşlardan itibaren
benim üzerime çok fazla sorumluluk
yüklemişti ve öyle bir dönem gelmişti ki
hayatımın maratonlaştığını hissetmeye
başladım sürekli bunu düşünüyorum yani
küçük yaşlardan itibaren çok çalıştım
çokça öğrendim
hayatımı güzel bir yere getirdim ama
sanki o kadar çok sorumluluk yükledim ki
kendime hayatı artık
kaçırıyorum gibi hissetmeye başladım
ve bir gün bir gece bir kabus gördüm
kabusunda vücudumu hareket
ettiremediğimi görmüştüm
Gece uyandım
bacaklarıma dokundum
Oh dedim hareket ettirebiliyorum
o gün
çok değişik bir korku aldı içimi
monoton'da açtığını hissettiğim bir
hayatım var
aynı zamanda
sağlığıma şükrediyorum ama içime de
sağlamla ilgili bir korku yerleşmişti
bu kabusu aylarca düşündüm hiç
unutamadım bir gün arkadaşımla birlikte
dışarı çıkmıştık o hızlı bir şekilde
araba kullanıyor
yine bu kabusu hatırladım ve arkadaşıma
şu cümleyi kurdum ya dedim Şu arabayı
çok daha hızlı kullan direk bizi Öldür
Ya da dedim Lütfen yavaş kullan Beni
sakat filan bırakma
o Tabii otoban faresi arabasıyla makas
atmaya devam etti
bunları hissettiğim dönemde
her şey yine böyle üst üste içinde
sıkıntı yaratmaya devam ediyordu ve
tarih 23 Mayıs 2013
arkadaşımla birlikte bir yazılım
projesinde çalışıyoruz onun okulunun
Üniversitesini ofis olarak kullanıyoruz
Ben evden çıkacağım onun yanına
gideceğim birlikte okulda çalışacağız
Ben her şey son dakika yetişen işte son
dakika hazırlanan bir karakterim yine
çok hızlı bir şekilde hazırlandım evimiz
4 kattaydı basamakları beşer beşer
atladım aşağı indim otobüse bindim
otobüsün camına kafamı yasladım
yine bir şeyleri sorguluyorum niye her
şeyi bu şekilde son dakika yetişiyorum
niye bu kadar çok koşturuyorum diye
sorgulamaya devam ediyorum
dışarıda bir kaza gördüm
kazaya baktım çok ilgimi çekti dedim ki
keşke benim de hayatımda iyi ya da kötü
bir şey olsa da şu maratonluk gitse
okula geldim arkadaşımla buluştum
çalışmamız gerekiyor
ama benim İçimden çalışmak gelmiyor
o sırada telefonum çaldı ofisten dışarı
çıktım
geri geldiğimde arkadaşım bilgisayarın
başında uyuya kalmıştı
ve benim Bilgisayarımın olduğu yerde de
başka birisi başını koymuş o da uyuya
kalmıştı Ben de bunu fırsat bildim
Çünkü içimin çok sıkıldığı bir gündü
Bilgisayarıma aldım dışarı çıktım okudum
bahçesi minderlerden kurulu bir alandı
Ve inanılmaz bir kalabalık vardı o gün
mindere doğru yaklaştım tek baş olan
mindere doğru yaklaştım yanında oturanda
bir çocuk vardı buraya oturabilir miyim
dedim Tabii kardeşim Gel Otur dedi
oturdum
bacaklarımı uzattım kucağıma
Bilgisayarıma koydum
aradan biraz zaman geçti yine kendimi
çok sıkılmış hissediyorum Aslında
kalkmak istiyorum bilgisayarın ekranda
boş boş bakıyordum
ve kalkmak istemedim
Saniyeler sonra
önümde devrilen beyaz bir masa gördüm
başımda inanılmaz bir acı hissettim
etrafımda insanlar toplanmaya başlamıştı
deniz sesi duydum
ve gözümün önünden o bahsedilen meşhur
film şeridi geçmeye başladı
gördüm kabusu hatırladım
ve daha ne olduğunu bile anlamadan
tekerlekli sandalye üzerinde gördüm
kendimi
kaldırımlardan çıkmaya çalıştığımı
gördüm
ve bir mücadele içinde gördüm
sonra şu cümleyi kurdum
Galiba dedim
Monotonluk
bitti
ameliyata girene kadar
bilincim açıktı her şeyi hatırlıyorum
ve
gözlerimi
yoğun bakımda açtım gözlerimi açtığımda
Entübe edilmiş bir şekilde yatıyordum
Kollarımı kaldırıyorum bunu çıkartın
demeye çalışıyorum
çıkartmadılar konuşamıyorum
aldığım nefesi bile kendim kontrol
edemiyorum
yaşadığım kazadan çok daha büyük bir
acıydı
sonra saatler geçtikten sonra
artık o sonuncu yazın çıkarmışlardı ve
hemşirelere üst üste sorular sormaya
başladım
Ben ne yaşadım başıma ne geldi
öğreniyorum ki
başıma düşen masa
C6 seviyesinde boyun omurumu kırıyor ve
omuriliğime hasar veriyor ameliyat
öncesinde doktorlar %20'lik bir yaşam
ihtimali yaşam ihtimalinden
bahsediyorlar ve aileme çok fazla bir
şey beklemeyin diyorlar Çünkü orada
oluşan adam neredeyse solunum durdurma
noktasına gelmiş
Belki de bir üst kemiğimi kırsam
kollarım bile hareket ettiremeyecektim
ve o kırılan kemikten sonra
ellerimi bileklerimden itibaren
kaybediyorum göz altından itibaren Bütün
vücudumun kontrolünü kaybediyorum
yoğun bakımda 6 gün boyunca yattım
bu dönemde bir şeyleri sorgulama
fırsatım oldu o tavana baktığım günlerde
yaşadığım her şeyi düşündüm
ve gördüm kabus geldi aklıma
Bu Yaşadığım olayın bir tesadüf
olamayacağına inandım Çünkü bu hayatta
herkesin bir amacı bir Misyonu var benim
üzerime de bence böyle bir misyon
yüklenmişti
diğer tüm insanlara vermem gereken bir
mesaj vardı
ve Kendime şunu söyledim
yaşadığım Bu olaydan sonra
öyle bir mücadele vereceksin ki
insanlar seni gördüğünde sana acıyarak
bakmayacaklar Sen bir şükür sebebi
olmayacaksın
insanlar senin mücadelene öyle
bakacaklar ki
insanlar seni örnek alacaklar
insanlara ilham olacaksın dedim
ve Kendime şunu söyledim
çocukluğumdan beri düşüncelerimle birçok
şeyi çözebiliyorum
ve bunu zihninde çöz
yoğun bakımdan çıktıktan sonra hastane
odasında bir süreç başladı ve hiç
hareket ettiremediğim bedenimi
düşüncelerimle hareket ettirmeye
çalışıyorum her gün yoğun bakıma özür
dilerim Her gün fizik tedaviye giderken
sol işaret parmağım bu şekilde
kaldırmaya çalışıyordum her gün
düşüncelerimle oynatmaya çalışıyordum ve
bir gün geldiğinde ben işaret Parmağımı
artık hareket ettirebiliyorum
işaret parmağım benim en büyük umudum
olmuştu ve belki de düşünce gücümle
çözebildiğime inandığım en büyük hareket
olmuştu
Hastane odasında 8 ay boyunca yattım
ailemle birlikte orayı evimiz olarak
gördük
ve odadan çıktıktan sonra eve döndükten
sonra Aslında yeni bir mücadele
başlıyordu
tabi Ailem artık çok korkmuştu başıma
böyle bir olay gelmesinden dolayı çok
endişelilerdi tekrar böyle bir şeyin
yaşanmasından çok endişelilerdi ama ben
hep Kendime şunu söylüyordum benim
sosyal hayatın içine katılmam lazım
adapte olmam lazım bir şeyleri çözmem
lazım
bağımsız bir şekilde yaşamaya çalışmam
lazım diyordum
ve bununla ilgili araştırırken
öğreniyorum ki
tekerlek sandalye kullanan insanlar
ellerini kullanamayan Hatta kollarını
kullanamayan kolları olmayan insanlar
bile araba kullanabiliyorlar
bunu öğrendiğimde aileme söyledim ben
araba almak istiyorum Araba kullanmak
istiyorum dedim
ailem dedi ki arabayı biz alalım seni
nereye istiyorsan Biz götürelim Hayır
dedim ben istemiyorum
Ben dışarı çıkmak istiyorum hayatın
içinde yer almak istiyorum
O yüzden araba almak istiyorum dedim
onlar bana şunu söyledi ya Tekrar dışarı
çıktığında başına bir şey gelirse o
zaman ne yapacağız
cevap olarak şunu söyledim
dışarı
çıktığımda başıma ne gelebilir en fazla
ölürüm
Ama asıl ben evde kalırsam ölürüm
dedim
onları ikna ettim
daha kazadan bir buçuk sene sonra araba
kullanmaya başladım
ve bu şekilde Aslında hayatın içinde yer
almaya başladım
fizik tedaviye gittiğim bir dönem
başladı iki buçuk sene kadar yoğun bir
şekilde Fizik Tedavi aldım
ve bir gün fizik tedaviden dönerken
yolda babamı alıyorum birlikte eve
dönüyoruz babam
çalıştığı yerde tanıştığı bir milli
okçudan bahsediyor Kendisi de tekerlekli
sandalye kullanıyor ve benim için de
Okçuluk sporunu öneriyor
babam bundan bahsetme çok fazla
anlayamadım Hani Okçuluk sporunu gözünde
çok canlandıramadım Tamam dedim bir gün
denerim bakarım
aradan aylar geçti
ben tabii hiç düşünmüyorum bununla
alakalı benim çocukluk arkadaşım
internetten aldığı bir şeyden dolayı bir
dolandırıcılık olayı yaşıyor bunu
şikayet etmek için adliyeye gidiyoruz ve
orada
babamın o tanıştığı kişiyle ben karşıda
okçulukla ilgili konuşmaya başlıyoruz
sonrasında merak ediyorum bir hafta
sonra yanına gidiyorum antrenmanını
izliyorum
antrenman izleyince çok etkileniyorum
ve görüyorum ki bu durağan bir spor
Mental olarak kuvvet gerektiren bir spor
Ben diyorum bu işi yaparım
50 metre mesafeden atışlar yapıp hepsini
merkeze gönderiyor o gün Kendime şunu
söylüyorum Bir gün ben öyle bir ok
atacağım ki
bütün oklarım böyle merkeze gidecek
hepsini ondan vuracağım çok iyi Balıkçı
olacağım Herkes diyecek Yiğit çok iyi
bir okçu beni örnek gösterecekler Tabi
bu hayali kurduğum gün
merak edip yayı elime almak istiyorum
yayı elime almamla birlikte sandalyeden
düşmem bir oluyor ve anlıyorum ki bu iş
o kadar da Kolay Olmayacak
ama o gün
Bir Hayal kuruyorum
ve Bu işin peşini bırakmayacağım
yapabileceğim en iyisini hedefleyeceğim
Ve sonunda ne olursa olsun buradan devam
edeceğim diyorum kendime
ve
ilk okulumu atmaya başlıyorum 2015'in
sonlarına doğru
Tabii ilk zamanlar tekerlek sandalye
bile kullanamıyorum
Ellerimi kullanamıyorum Bu yüzden ok
atmak benim için bir mucize gibi
aparatlar yapıyorum Kemer kullanıyorum
kullandığım aparatlarla birlikte hem
dengemi sağlıyorum hem Atış yapmaya
başlıyorum İlk zamanlar hep karavana
gidiyor oklarım ve kendimi geliştirmek
için
evin otoparkında bir antrenman alanı
kurmaya karar veriyorum burada günde 5-6
saat annemin yardımıyla antrenmanlar
yapıyorum
ve yaptığım antrenmanlar
o kadar beni geliştiriyor ki 2017
yılında Milli Takım kampına davet
ediliyorum
ve burada
milli takıma seçiliyorum 2017 senesinde
ilk defa milli forma giyiyorum ve
katıldım ilk yarışmada takım
kategorisinde iki tane dünya rekoru
kırarak dünya şampiyonluğuna ulaşıyorum
ve başarı beni çok motive ediyor artık
insanlara anlatabileceğim bir hikaye var
Bunu biliyorum ve insanlara hikaye
anlatmaya başlıyorum ve devamında da hep
şunu söylüyorum Ben dünyanın en iyi
sporcularından biri olacağım hedeflerim
yüksek koyuyorum tabi Hep yolunda
gitmiyor her şey Ama kendime söylediğim
bir şey var öyle bir mücadele vereceğim
ki öyle çalışacağım ki kaybettiğimde
bile çok güzel kaybedeceğim
bu şekilde çalışmaya devam ediyorum ama
2018 senesinde Milli takım kampında sağ
akciğerim sönüyor Avrupa şampiyonasına 3
hafta önce akciğer sönmesi yaşayıp 8 gün
hastanede yatıyorum ve o gün tekrar
kendime söz veriyorum ve diyorum ki
buradan da bir geri dönüş yapacağım 2019
Yılında İtalya'da Avrupa Kupası'nda ilk
bireysel şampiyonluğumu kazanıyorum aynı
zamanda takım şampiyonluğu da elde
ediyoruz ve bu yarışmanın benim için
şöyle bir anlamı var
Ben Türkiye'nin ilk tekerlek sandalye
televizyon programı sunucusu oldum bir
spor programı sundum
ve o yarışmadan sonra kendi
şampiyonluğumun anonsunu yaptım
bu inanılmaz bir duyguydu benim için
belki Dünyada başka bir örneği bile
yoktur
2019'un işte nisan ayında yarışmaya
gidiyoruz ve aradan bir ay geçtikten
sonra Hollanda'da bir dünya
şampiyonasına katılıyoruz orada takım
kategorisinde bir dünya şampiyonu daha
kazanıyoruz yine dünya rekoru kırıyoruz
ve her sene Aslında başarı
akmaya devam ediyor
ama amacım her zaman bireysel olarak
şampiyonluk kazanmaktı
ve 2022 yılı geldiğinde
Dubai'de dünya şampiyonasında hem
bireyselde hem takımda dünya şampiyonu
oluyorum Bir yarışmada 2 6 madalya
kazanıyorum
yine Avrupa şampiyonasında işte
Konya'daki İslami dayanışma oyunlarında
madalyalar kazanıyorum ve bu sene benim
gerçekten kariyerimin en iyi
sezonlarından biriydi 3 uluslararası
yarışmada yarışmada ile kazandım
Rekorlar başarılar madalyalar ödüller
Aslında benim sadece hikayemi anlatmaktı
ki bir araç
Ben bugün
Burada çok farklı bir hikaye de
anlatıyor olabilirim belki bir yazılım
şirketinin sahibi olarak başarılarımı
Hatta
başarısızlıklarımı anlatıyor olabilirdim
ama okçulukla gelen böyle bir hikaye
oldu
hayat bize
Yollar sunar o yolları takip etmemizi
ister Bazen de o yolları aşmamızı bekler
ben bu yolculuğu çok seviyorum
hayat bize Tek seferlik deneme fırsatı
verilen bir tecrübe
hayatta başımıza Sadece iyi şeyler
gelmez kötü şeyler de gelir
önemli olan
kötü şeyleri bile yaşadığımızda onun
anlamını bulabilmektir
bir gün sahip olduğun her şeyi
kaybedebilirsin sıfır görebilirsin
Peki biz her durumda
en iyi versiyonumuzu ortaya koyuyor
muyuz yoksa önümüze engeller mi
koyuyoruz
ancak engel yapabileceğim bir şey
yapmamaktır
ve bazen de sıfır
birden büyüktür
[Alkış]